بعد عشرين عاما من الحرب على العراق ماذا
حل بممتلكات الرئيس السابق ضمن سلسله من
التقارير عدتها العربيه عن قصور صدام
ويخوته سنتحدث عن قصر الاعظميه او كما
يقال ان اسمه قصره وقيل ان صدام منحه
لزوجته انذاك
[موسيقى]
كان موقع هذا القصر بين ساحه الدلال
وكورنيش الاعظميه في المنطقه التي سمي
القصر على اسمها في الجزء الشمالي من
العاصمه بغداد ويضم 600 غرفه وقعت
اجتماعات فضلا عن اثني عشر مسبحا وبحيره
صيد للاسماك
بني القصر من الحجر العراقي والجرانيت
الايطالي والمرمر اللبناني بنقش العباسيه
واندلسيه ومنذ تاريخ انشائه عام
1995 وحتى عام 2003 تعرض القصر للقصف
الامريكي عده مرات
[موسيقى]
كان لهذا القصر اهميه لدى الرئيس الراحل
جعله في نهايه التسعينيات مقرا لاستقبال
كبار الشخصيات من ضيوفه واحتضن العصر
العديد من الاجتماعات والمؤتمرات ولم
تنتهي اهميه قصر السياسيه بعد عام 2003
[موسيقى]
بعد الحرب تحول القصر الى مقر للجيش
الامريكي ثم اصبح مقرا للجيش العراقي وفي
بدايه عام 2018 كانت هنالك نوايا لتحويل
القصر الى مستشفى لعلاج مدمني المخدرات
لكن في منتصف عام 2018 تحول القصر الى
منتجع سياحي
[موسيقى]
الان هو بعد 20 عاما من الحرب على العراق
اصبح القصر منتجعا سياحيا على طراز حكايات
الف ليله وليله يزوره السائحون من
الصائمين لتناول وجبه الفطور فضلا عن
اقامه فعاليات رمضانيه فيه
[موسيقى]